Tasha: 我也开始了
Tasha: I'm starting too.
Jake:等下来吧我们一起对个时间
Jake: Come down later, we'll sync the time.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:但是能可以先开始聊
Jake: But we can start chatting first.
Tasha: 那我们开始做早饭吧
Tasha: Let's start making breakfast.
Lucia: 那我把这个眼镜刚好擦一下
Lucia: Then I'll just clean these glasses real quick.
Tasha: 我们去做那个面饼部分
Tasha: We'll handle the dough part.
Tasha: 你来冲咖啡或者做早上的牛牛奶
Tasha: You can make coffee or prepare the morning milk.
Lucia: 可以可以呃你指哪种牛奶
Lucia: Sure, sure. Uh, which milk do you mean?
Tasha: 鲜牛奶
Tasha: Fresh milk.
Lucia: 只要把牛奶倒出来就可以的牛奶吗
Lucia: The kind you just pour out and it's ready?
Tasha: 热一热吧
Tasha: Warm it up a bit.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Tasha: 你早上喝冰牛奶吗
Tasha: Do you drink cold milk in the morning?
Lucia: 没有没有我以为你要给牛奶里面添加什么
Lucia: No, no. I thought you wanted to add something to it.
Tasha: 那我们那我们摊个饼吧就
Tasha: Then let's just make some pancakes.
Jake:摊可以摊
Jake: Pancakes are fine.
Katrina:  都行
Katrina: Anything works.
Alice:咖啡在这个
Alice: The coffee is here.
Tasha: 你觉得这么多够了吗
Tasha: Do you think this much is enough?
Alice:嗯能做
Alice: Hmm, that should do.
Tasha: 我觉只需要打3个蛋就够了啊
Tasha: I think just three eggs should be enough.
Alice: 2个
Alice: Two eggs.
Katrina:  就是那天海底捞送的
Katrina: These are from that Haidilao meal.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Tasha: 好吧再来一些吧
Tasha: Alright, let's add some more then.
Alice:哎呀差不多 因为我不吃
Alice: That should be enough since I don't eat it.
Tasha: 那就这么多吧也不用做很多我觉得
Tasha: Let's stick with this amount. We don't need to make a lot.
Tasha: 毕竟中午还要吃饭
Tasha: We still have lunch after all.
Tasha: 我就倒一一3个4个就行
Tasha: I'll just pour three or four, that's enough.
Tasha:因为
Tasha: Because...
Alice:够吗
Alice: Is that enough?
Tasha: 再再倒一些
Tasha: Pour some more.
Lucia:  sorry按错键了
Lucia: Sorry, pressed the wrong button.
Jake: 好
Jake: It's okay.
Lucia: 再来一次
Lucia: Let's try again.
Jake: 嗯嗯
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 这好晒啊
Tasha: It's so sunny here.
Alice:我来吧
Alice: I'll handle it.
Tasha: 然后再加水就行了是吧
Tasha: Then just add water and it's done, right?
Lucia:  sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Jake: 没关系挺好
Jake: No worries, it's fine.
Tasha: 就这样调面糊吧
Tasha: Let's just mix the batter like this.
Tasha: 哈哈我们家就这样调然后直接开摊
Tasha: Haha, in our house, we mix it like this and then start cooking.
Katrina:  赠品
Katrina: Freebie!
Alice: 因为我一般用的是筷子
Alice: Because I usually use chopsticks.
Tasha: oh
Tasha: Oh
Alice:没用过这个
Alice: I've never used this before.
Tasha: 接瓶水
Tasha: Hand me a bottle of water.
Tasha: 我觉得应该到矿泉水
Tasha: I think we should use mineral water.
Lucia: 呃我时间是写10
Lucia: Um, I wrote the time as 10.
Alice: 我们应该放在那个大一点的面盆里
Alice: We should put it in a bigger mixing bowl.
Jake: 好的43 没没关系
Jake: Alright, 43, no, it's fine.
Tasha: 嗯这个里面我主要觉得有这个嘴好摊
Tasha: Hmm, I think this one is good for spreading.
Alice:不好搅你给我拿个筷子吧
Alice: It's hard to stir, can you get me some chopsticks?
Jake: 那你们俩聊聊舞蹈
Jake: You guys can chat about dance.
Jake: 在冲完牛奶之后
Jake: After making the milk.
Tasha: 没事我来
Tasha: It's okay, I'll do it.
Lucia:  哎呦可以选一下
Lucia: Oh, we can choose here.
Jake: 哦对对然后你们可以在这比划比划
Jake: Oh yes, then you can try it out here.
Alice:这个
Alice: This one.
Alice: 你们家里面鸡蛋饼是比较稀的
Alice: Are the egg pancakes in your house more runny?
Alice: 还是比较稠的
Alice: Or thicker?
Jake: 哈哈哈二楼相机没有布好
Jake: Haha, the camera on the second floor isn't set up well.
Tasha: 比较顺滑的
Tasha: It's smoother.
Jake: 所以没办法上去比划
Jake: So we can't go up there to show.
Lucia:  这里如果有美团的话地址怎么选
Lucia: If we use Meituan here, how do we select the address?
Alice: 你看不好弄
Alice: See, it's hard to use.
Jake: 地址是
Jake: The address is...
Alice:拿筷子吧
Alice: Just use the chopsticks.
Tasha: 筷子还得洗
Tasha: The chopsticks need to be washed too.
Alice: 你这个不也得洗吗
Alice: You need to wash this too.
Lucia:  53号
Lucia: Number 53.
Alice: 给我吧
Alice: Give it to me.
Jake: 哦对就是把31改成53
Jake: Oh yeah, just change 31 to 53.
Jake: 因为31他找不到他要绕圈
Jake: Because they can't find 31, they have to go in circles.
Lucia:  我的网络又开始不太给力了
Lucia: My internet is getting weak again.
Lucia:  居然是这样
Lucia: That's why.
Lucia:  要买一个碘伏脚蹭破了
Lucia: I need to buy some iodine, I scraped my foot.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Jake: 那我可以问问这个管家
Jake: Then I can ask the housekeeper about it.
Alice: 我先帮你搅着吧
Alice: I'll stir this for you first.
Lucia:  如果他有的话
Lucia: If he has it.
Katrina:  这边他们是不打扫卫生是吗
Katrina: They don't clean here, do they?
Jake: 呃可以跟他们说他们就对
Jake: Uh, you can tell them and they'll do it.
Lucia:  让他来打扫
Lucia: Ask him to clean.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:太绸了
Alice: It's so sticky.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 哎对京东是你要让让
Jake: Hey, right, for JD you need to...
Jake: 你什么时候去
Jake: When are you going?
Tasha: 下午他走了
Tasha: He left in the afternoon.
Jake: 嗯OK
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Katrina:  就是昨天我们拿快递那个
Katrina: It's about the delivery we got yesterday.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina:  他不是固定的
Katrina: He's not a regular.
Tasha: 感觉这个村
Tasha: Feels like this village...
Lucia:  我连有关系吗
Lucia: Does it even matter?
Katrina:  外来人员
Katrina: Outsiders.
Lucia:  但是我看对
Lucia: But I see...
Katrina:  随时来探望我们一下
Katrina: They come to check on us sometimes.
Jake: 卡住了是吗
Jake: Stuck, right?
Lucia:  我看我看
Lucia: Let me see, let me see.
Jake: 应该没有什么
Jake: Shouldn't be a problem.
Lucia:  您好像能正确使用美团
Lucia: You seem to use Meituan correctly.
Lucia:  我觉得应该不是这个原因
Lucia: I don't think that's the reason.
Tasha: 啊没关系
Tasha: Ah, it's fine.
Jake: 对美团的问题
Jake: Yeah, Meituan's issue.
Tasha: no not at all
Tasha: No, not at all.
Jake: 这是那次海底捞的视频
Jake: This is the video from Hai Di Lao.
Tasha: 还会再稀一点
Tasha: It can be thinner.
Tasha: 面水加多了加面面加多了加水
Tasha: Add more water if the dough is too thick, more dough if it's too watery.
Alice:是这样的
Alice: That's how it is.
Jake: 这么多种子
Jake: So many seeds.
Jake: 他要种什么东西
Jake: What's he going to plant?
Katrina:  这应该是土吧
Katrina: This should be soil, right?
Katrina:  这是草莓
Katrina: These are strawberries.
Tasha: 拿还剩个鸡蛋怎么办呢呵呵
Tasha: What to do with the leftover egg, haha.
Katrina:  这是赠送的樱桃萝卜
Katrina: These are free cherry radishes.
Jake: 啊还能种樱桃
Jake: Oh, you can still grow cherries.
Alice:先放进去
Alice: Put it in first.
Jake: 呵呵樱桃不是种很久吗
Jake: Haha, don't cherries take a long time to grow?
Katrina:  哈哈海底捞
Katrina: Haha, Haidilao.
Katrina:  怎么海底捞的业务
Katrina: How's Haidilao's business?
Jake: 樱桃树你种过吗
Jake: Have you ever planted a cherry tree?
Katrina:  啊樱桃不是树吗
Katrina: Ah, aren't cherries trees?
Tasha: 吃过算吗
Tasha: Does eating them count?
Katrina:  他怎么能给我种呢
Katrina: How can he plant them for me?
Jake: 呵呵呵吃过差不多
Jake: Haha, eating them is close enough.
Alice: 你要的稠度吗
Alice: Is this the consistency you wanted?
Tasha: 还要再稀一点
Tasha: It needs to be a bit thinner.
Alice: 那你得放水
Alice: Then you need to add water.
Jake: 点上了吗
Jake: Is it on?
Alice: 你就放这一点
Alice: Just add this much.
Lucia:  nope因为飘到外星球去了
Lucia: Nope, because it floated to another planet.
Tasha: 我又怕放多了
Tasha: I'm afraid of adding too much.
Alice: 没事我来了我就有点费劲
Alice: It's okay, I got this, but it's a bit tricky.
Lucia:  奇怪啊
Lucia: Weird.
Jake: 你用的是美团外卖是吧
Jake: You're using Meituan delivery, right?
Lucia:  就我直接点了美团的APP
Lucia: Yeah, I just used the Meituan app.
Lucia: 然后它里面会有这个
Lucia: Then it has this option.
Lucia: 我刚才里面已经搞好了但是那是一个
Lucia: I already set it up inside, but that was...
Tasha: 我在想要不要那个搅拌器
Tasha: I'm wondering if we need a mixer.
Tasha: 会不会搅拌的更顺一点
Tasha: Would it blend more smoothly?
Lucia:  53 嗯
Lucia: 53, hmm.
Tasha: 感觉有颗粒感
Tasha: It feels grainy.
Lucia:  我是输入53吗
Lucia: Should I input 53?
Alice: 你不是要弄更多吗
Alice: Weren't you going to add more?
Lucia:  因为我看他那里还有一个
Lucia: Because I saw there's another one there.
Lucia:  就是就算你输入
Lucia: Even if you input it...
Lucia:  他要你选定位还是什么的
Lucia: It asks you to choose a location or something.
Jake: 您直接输就好了
Jake: You can just input it directly.
Tasha: 他最后就是滑起来没有阻力的那种
Tasha: It should slide without any resistance in the end.
Tasha: 你懂我的状态吗
Tasha: Do you get what I mean?
Alice: 其实
Alice: Actually...
Alice: 蛋液应该后放
Alice: The egg should be added last.
Alice: 因为蛋液一放进去
Alice: Because once you add the egg...
Alice: 他把那个面给裹住了
Alice: It coats the flour.
Lucia:  哦我看一下您这个
Lucia: Oh, let me take a look at this.
Jake: 我不知道美团有可能也有用
Jake: I don't know, Meituan could also be useful.
Alice: 还好
Alice: It's fine.
Alice: 没关系早饭而已
Alice: No worries, it's just breakfast.
Lucia:  你的APP名字就叫美团外卖
Lucia: Your app's name is Meituan Waimai.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia:  下个APP我操
Lucia: Next app, damn.
Katrina:  舞蹈
Katrina: Dance.
Alice: 是你要的是再稀一点还是
Alice: Do you want it thinner or...
Tasha: 我靠怎么这么稠真的是用低筋面粉吗
Tasha: Oh my god, why is this so thick? Is this really low-gluten flour?
Tasha: 我怎么记得是用糯米粉
Tasha: I remember using glutinous rice flour.
Alice:什么 糯米粉
Alice: What? Glutinous rice flour?
Tasha: 糯米粉我们家好像用糯米粉
Tasha: Glutinous rice flour. My family seems to use glutinous rice flour.
Katrina:  那我们跳舞是不是还要带上修硕一起
Katrina: Should we bring Shure along for the dance?
Lucia:  我也在想
Lucia: I was thinking the same.
Lucia:  至少我们练的时候要大家要带上
Lucia: At least when we practice, everyone should be included.
Tasha: 因为感觉这种有点起劲的感觉
Tasha: Because it feels kind of exciting.
Lucia:  那会很影响
Lucia: It will affect the choreography.
Katrina:  上再教他也没事
Katrina: It's fine to teach him too.
Lucia:  会影响一些动作
Lucia: It will affect some moves.
Katrina:  不是如果是有男生加入的话
Katrina: If a guy joins...
Alice: 这是低筋面粉
Alice: This is low-gluten flour.
Katrina:  那个舞蹈风格就
Katrina: The dance style will...
Alice: 没关系都是面
Alice: It's okay, it's all flour.
Tasha: 好奇怪啊
Tasha: So strange.
Jake: 你可以不加入
Jake: You can choose not to join.
Jake: 也可以加入都是你们说了算
Jake: Or join, it's up to you all.
Lucia:  要不就加入吧
Lucia: Let's just have him join.
Tasha: 这是最后一次水
Tasha: This is the last water.
Katrina:  啊啊
Katrina: Ahh.
Katrina:  来吧一起社死吧
Katrina: Come on, let's socially die together.
Alice: 我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
Katrina:  我找找
Katrina: I'll check.
Katrina:  我问问我同学他们之前跳过什么
Katrina: I'll ask my classmates what they danced before.
Tasha: 天呐感觉很失败哈哈哈
Tasha: Oh man, feels like a failure, hahaha.
Alice: 你放调料了吗
Alice: Did you add seasoning?
Tasha: 没有不是加糖吗
Tasha: No, isn't it supposed to be sugar?
Lucia:  但我觉得我这次穿来的衣服里面
Lucia: But I think the outfit I wore this time...
Alice: 没加呢我不会做甜的
Alice: I didn't add it. I don't know how to make sweets.
Lucia:  最适合的可能就是这条
Lucia: The best fit might be these...
Lucia:  这条裤子和那个白色上衣了
Lucia: These pants and that white top.
Tasha: 嗯我们是蘸也可以直接现在加
Tasha: Hmm, we can dip it or just add it now.
Lucia:  我们也可以不那么统一
Lucia: We don't have to be that uniform.
Alice: 哎等一下这个是你想要的稠度吗
Alice: Hey, wait, is this the consistency you want?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Uh-huh.
Lucia:  就是服装风格差不多就可以了
Lucia: Just make sure the clothing style is similar, that's enough.
Tasha: 可以吧差不多就这样吧
Tasha: Yeah, that should be fine.
Alice: 你放糖进去
Alice: You added the sugar?
Alice: 直接这样放糖它会不会不融化呀
Alice: Will the sugar not dissolve if you add it like this?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 好吧那就这样吧
Tasha: Okay, let's just do it this way then.
Katrina:  直接穿那种纸质的衣服
Katrina: Just wear those paper clothes.
Alice: 你是不是得调糖水或者怎么的
Alice: Shouldn't you mix the sugar with water or something?
Lucia:  我们的杯子在那边OK
Lucia: Our cups are over there, okay.
Katrina:  哎这好苦
Katrina: Oh, this is so bitter.
Jake: 也也不一定
Jake: Not necessarily.
Jake: 自己做不一定节省预预算
Jake: Making it yourself doesn't always save budget.
Tasha: 嗯麻烦可恶仔
Tasha: Hmm, it's troublesome, annoying.
Katrina:  我加了他倒进来就这么多
Katrina: I added it, but it's only this much.
Katrina:  然后我加了这么多牛奶还是很苦
Katrina: And I added so much milk, but it's still bitter.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia:  那都有谁喝咖啡啊
Lucia: So, who drinks coffee here?
Lucia:  我统计一下
Lucia: I'll take a count.
Lucia:  不喝咖啡的啊
Lucia: Who doesn't drink coffee?
Alice: 我来一个吧
Alice: I'll have one.
Lucia:  一个你喝吗
Lucia: One, are you drinking?
Jake: 来喝我也喝
Jake: I'll drink, I will.
Alice: 算了我不来了
Alice: Never mind, I won't.
Tasha: 我要喝牛奶
Tasha: I want milk.
Lucia:  呃要咖里面要不要咖啡您算上了
Lucia: Uh, do you want coffee in your milk?
Lucia:  哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:  雨轩还喝咖啡吗
Lucia: Does Yuxuan still drink coffee?
Katrina:  这密Wifi密码
Katrina: This is the Wifi password.
Jake: 哎呀挡住了挡住了挡住了
Jake: Oh no, it's blocked, blocked, blocked.
Lucia:  那现在就两个人挡住
Lucia: So now two people are blocking it.
Jake: 对也挡住了
Jake: Yeah, it's blocked too.
Katrina:  Wifi密码是多少上来的
Katrina: What's the Wifi password?
Jake: 这儿
Jake: Here.
Alice: 我来一个吧
Alice: I'll have one.
Jake: 怎么还有指纹呢
Jake: Why is there a fingerprint?
Tasha: 来一个什么
Tasha: Have one what?
Alice: 喝的
Alice: Drinking.
Tasha: 你刚刚不是报名了咖啡吗
Tasha: Didn't you just sign up for coffee?
Alice: 对啊但是我又取消了
Alice: Yeah, but then I canceled it.
Alice: 我现在报一下
Alice: I'll sign up again now.
Lucia:  啊那你重新报名哈哈
Lucia: Ah, so you're signing up again, haha.
Lucia:  我们的咖啡名额减少到一个
Lucia: We only have one coffee slot left now.
Alice: 刚刚已经把我算上了总共才两个
Alice: They already counted me, so there are only two total.
Lucia:  对对因为我我我现在不是特别困
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, because I'm not super sleepy right now.
Lucia:  所以我先不喝
Lucia: So I'm not drinking it for now.
Alice: OK我只是想有个味道
Alice: OK, I just wanted the taste.
Lucia:  然后雨轩刚已经喝过了
Lucia: And Yuxuan already drank some.
Lucia:  那你喝什么呢
Lucia: What are you drinking?
Alice: 咖啡吧
Alice: Coffee, I guess.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia:  哎呀哈哈
Lucia: Oh, haha.
Lucia:  对方撤出
Lucia: They withdrew.
Lucia:  撤回了一条消息又发送了
Lucia: Withdrew a message and sent it again.
Lucia:  一样的是吧
Lucia: It's the same, right?
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:  剩下的人都喝牛奶吗
Lucia: Are the rest of you drinking milk?
Lucia:  嗯找一个小锅
Lucia: Hmm, find a small pot.
Jake: 路亚是买好了吗
Jake: Did you already buy the lures?
Tasha: 感觉水有点多
Tasha: Feels like there's too much water.
Lucia:  啊什么啊还没呢
Lucia: Huh, what? Not yet.
Jake: 买好还买
Jake: Buy them again?
Jake: 那我先放在
Jake: Then I'll put them first.
Jake: 或者我联系一下修硕
Jake: Or I'll contact Shure.
Jake: 哎先联系一下收垃圾
Jake: Hey, contact the garbage collector first.
Lucia:  或许可以问一下他们就是民宿这边
Lucia: Maybe we can ask the people at the B&B here.
Tasha: 害怕
Tasha: Scared.
Lucia:  有没有碘伏或者酒精
Lucia: If they have iodine or alcohol.
Jake: 嗯嗯好
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Alice: 都是食物我能做做不了
Alice: It's all food, I can make it or not.
Lucia:  因为我我刚刷了一下
Lucia: Because I just refreshed it.
Lucia:  他还没有刷新出来
Lucia: It hasn't refreshed yet.
Katrina:  你们听过这个歌吗
Katrina: Have you heard this song?
Katrina:  就这个舞很简单
Katrina: This dance is really simple.
Lucia:  我好像听过让我看一眼
Lucia: I think I've heard it, let me take a look.
Tasha: 再加点面粉吧哈哈
Tasha: Add some more flour, haha.
Katrina:  非常简单
Katrina: It's very simple.
Katrina:  就是人家跳年会的舞
Katrina: It's just a dance from the annual party.
Katrina:  这是我们之前艺术团跳过跳着玩的
Katrina: We used to dance this for fun in our art troupe.
Lucia:  这个是一个抖音上很火的曲子吗
Lucia: Is this song very popular on TikTok?
Lucia:  觉得我好像在哪里听过
Lucia: I feel like I've heard it somewhere before.
Katrina:  钥匙
Katrina: Keys.
Jake: 这是一个经典的一个
Jake: This is a classic one.
Alice: 可以吧我觉得这个差不多就好
Alice: I think this is good enough.
Katrina:  非常经典的
Katrina: It's very classic.
Tasha: 可以吧可以
Tasha: It's good, it's good.
Alice: 帮你搅吧就有点费力费手
Alice: Let me stir it for you, it's a bit tiring.
Jake: 这这是哪年
Jake: What year is this from?
Jake: 零几年的歌还是八几年的歌呀
Jake: Is it a song from the 2000s or the 80s?
Alice: 没关系不用帮我弄
Alice: It's okay, I don't need help.
Katrina:  失恋阵线联盟
Katrina: Love Alliance.
Jake: 这可能是八几年的歌
Jake: This might be a song from the 80s.
Katrina:  这倒是很简单
Katrina: This is actually very simple.
Tasha: 我发给他了吗
Tasha: Did I send it to him?
Lucia:  这个还蛮简单的
Lucia: This is quite simple.
Katrina:  就当时我们艺术团
Katrina: Back then, our art troupe...
Katrina:  男生可以跳的
Katrina: Guys could dance it too.
Katrina:  多长时间
Katrina: How long?
Katrina:  2分42 跳个2分钟
Katrina: 2 minutes 42 seconds, just dance for 2 minutes.
Katrina:  就跳个1分钟就可以了
Katrina: Just dance for 1 minute, that's enough.
Lucia:  而且动作幅度也不大
Lucia: And the movements aren't big.
Lucia:  其实整体来说戴个眼镜也没什么怪
Lucia: Actually, wearing glasses doesn't look weird at all.
Lucia:  你看他们也戴着呢哈哈哈
Lucia: Look, they are wearing them too, hahaha.
Katrina:  哎对哦
Katrina: Oh yeah.
Alice: 薇薇好了
Alice: Tasha, it's done.
Katrina:  我们可以搞一点造型pose
Katrina: We can do some poses.
Katrina:  一棵树哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Like a tree, hahaha.
Tasha: 好可以
Tasha: Okay, sure.
Alice: 可以吗
Alice: Is it okay?
Lucia:  啊哈哈哈 1棵树动作幅度这么大吗
Lucia: Hahaha, does the tree pose have such big movements?
Tasha: 我想看一下
Tasha: I want to see it.
Katrina:  搞一个那个树的头套
Katrina: Let's make a tree headgear.
Tasha: 那个铜锣烧是不是用低筋面粉
Tasha: For the dorayaki, do we use low-gluten flour?
Lucia:  他现在加载出来了
Lucia: It's loading now.
Alice: 铜锣烧
Alice: Dorayaki.
Katrina:  哦还有个你你你跳舞吗
Katrina: Oh, and you, you, you dance too?
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Tasha: 不用不用
Tasha: No need, no need.
Tasha: 这什么
Tasha: What's this?
Katrina:  这不是修硕最爱的摇滚吗
Katrina: Isn't this Shure's favorite rock music?
Tasha: 糯米粉好吧
Tasha: Glutinous rice flour, okay.
Tasha: 算了不学了
Tasha: Forget it, not learning it anymore.
Katrina:  这也可以
Katrina: This works too.
Katrina:  当我们闭室
Katrina: Let's just close the room.
Tasha: 啊我想要换个容器
Tasha: Ah, I want to change the container.
Lucia:  为什么这个
Lucia: Why this one?
Lucia:  看起来有一点哈哈
Lucia: It looks a bit... haha.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake: 你们想要换房间
Jake: You guys want to change rooms?
Katrina:  哎呦这还有一点什么元素呢
Katrina: Oh, there's a bit of something here.
Alice: 所以一开始为什么不用它呢
Alice: So why didn't we use it from the start?
Jake: 你你你们想要打扫房间吗
Jake: You, you guys want to clean the room?
Tasha: 呃我只是想过筛一下
Tasha: Uh, I just want to sift it.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  还有换队形
Katrina: And change the formation.
Lucia:  是我们要现在收拾一下扫描吗
Lucia: Should we tidy up and scan it now?
Alice: 这个稠度不好过筛
Alice: This consistency isn't good for sifting.
Jake: 呃也不是
Jake: Uh, not really.
Jake: 就是可以换
Jake: You can change it.
Tasha: 嗯也好过吧
Tasha: Hmm, it'll be fine.
Katrina:  哎这好看
Katrina: Oh, this looks nice.
Jake: 可以这个哎
Jake: This one works too.
Katrina:  这比刚刚那好看
Katrina: This looks better than the last one.
Alice: 呃那你试试吧
Alice: Uh, then give it a try.
Jake: 也可以啊
Jake: Sure, why not.
Katrina:  这还有点hip Hop元素
Katrina: This has a bit of hip-hop vibe.
Jake: 晚上我们也不是晚上
Jake: We'll clean it later, not now.
Tasha: 因为感觉里面有颗粒
Tasha: Because it feels grainy inside.
Jake: 可能下午我们就扫一下
Jake: Maybe we'll clean it this afternoon.
Jake: 他们先帮你们扫一下
Jake: They'll clean it first for you.
Jake: 你们再整理一下应该就好对
Jake: Then you can tidy up a bit more, and it should be fine.
Tasha: 但这个这个网确实太密了
Tasha: But this, this mesh is too fine.
Lucia:  哦也可以
Lucia: Oh, that works too.
Tasha: 哇像芝士
Tasha: Wow, it looks like cheese.
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: It's done.
Tasha: 买的网太密了
Tasha: The net we bought is too tight.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Tasha: 玛莎卡
Tasha: Masaka.
Alice: 我之前做章鱼小丸子的时候试过过筛
Alice: When I made takoyaki before, I tried sifting.
Katrina:  这这怎么又是SOLO
Katrina: Why is this another solo?
Alice: 确实不好过筛
Alice: It's really hard to sift.
Tasha: 等一下
Tasha: Wait a minute.
Katrina:  这咱就奇怪了
Katrina: This is so strange.
Lucia:  没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia:  我们可以把那个男生的站位给他删掉
Lucia: We can just remove the guy's spot.
Lucia:  反正我们也没那么多人
Lucia: Anyway, we don't have that many people.
Tasha: 稍等我一下
Tasha: Hold on for a sec.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Alice: 这做出来的差不多真的
Alice: This looks almost done, really.
Alice: 就是有颗粒的话
Alice: If there are granules...
Katrina:  偶像万万岁哦
Katrina: Long live idols!
Tasha: 嗯确实不太好过
Tasha: Yeah, it's really hard to sift.
Katrina:  高中的一个
Katrina: High school ones.
Alice: 真的熟了之后没啥区别
Alice: Once it's cooked, there's no difference.
Katrina:  还有女团舞
Katrina: And girl group dances.
Alice: 就那个口感上煎饼那之类的
Alice: The texture is similar to pancakes and such.
Katrina:  哈哈哈先开始
Katrina: Haha, let's start.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Katrina:  嗯还有那个偶像
Katrina: Yeah, and that idol.
Alice: 因为我之前做章鱼小丸子时候过筛
Alice: Because when I made takoyaki before, I sifted it.
Alice: 他不是更细
Alice: It wasn't finer.
Tasha:更细腻 对
Tasha: Finer, right.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 买的吗就是
Jake: You bought it, right?
Alice: 但是就是我那时候
Alice: But at that time...
Alice: 就是跟这种稠度差不多的那个
Alice: It was about the same consistency as this.
Alice: 过筛真是艰难的要死
Alice: Sifting was really so difficult.
Tasha: 巨难过筛
Tasha: Super hard to sift.
Lucia:  啊他没有碘伏是吧
Lucia: Ah, he doesn't have iodine?
Lucia:  那我就在美团订一个
Lucia: I'll just order one on Meituan.
Alice: 这样吧没关系
Alice: It's fine like this, no worries.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Jake: 嗯哦哦OK
Jake: Hmm, oh, okay.
Katrina:  我的未来事业
Katrina: My future career.
Tasha: 可以了没事
Tasha: It's okay now.
Tasha: OK上锅
Tasha: OK, put it on the stove.
Lucia:  53号楼
Lucia: Building 53.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:油
Alice: Oil.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Alice: 油在这
Alice: The oil is here.
Tasha: 铲子
Tasha: Spatula.
Alice: 这个能高温不能
Alice: Can this handle high heat?
Katrina:  好像广播体操
Katrina: Feels like a broadcast exercise.
Tasha: 这个不能
Tasha: This can't.
Alice: 不能
Alice: Can't?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 我靠这铲子怎么这么油
Tasha: Jeez, why is this spatula so oily?
Tasha: 受不了了好黏糊
Tasha: I can't stand it, it's so sticky.
Alice:我喝凉的就行
Alice: I'll just have it cold.
Alice: 不用给我弄热的
Alice: No need to heat it for me.
Lucia:  呃没事反正牛奶会变成热的
Lucia: Uh, it's fine, the milk will get warm anyway.
Lucia:  所以你也可以加热牛奶
Lucia: So you can heat the milk too.
Lucia:  万一你in case you change your mind
Lucia: Just in case you change your mind.
Alice: 噢不不不哈哈
Alice: Oh no no no, haha.
Alice: 不不不不
Alice: No no no.
Jake: 哈哈哈有了一手啊
Jake: Haha, got a trick up your sleeve.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Alice: no no no no no
Alice: No no no no no.
Alice: 我不喝我不喝热的
Alice: I don't drink it hot.
Jake: 哈哈哈有了一手
Jake: Haha, got a trick up your sleeve.
Alice: 牛奶我喝凉的就行了啊
Alice: I'll just have cold milk, okay?
Tasha: 啊不要放在这里
Tasha: Ah, don't put it here.
Lucia:  不我不我不放我啊你
Lucia: No, I won't put it. Ah, you...
Lucia:  你的意思是你要用这个锅是吗
Lucia: You mean you want to use this pot, right?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia:  啊没有没有我不用这个锅
Lucia: Ah, no no, I won't use this pot.
Lucia:  我只是把这个在这里放一下
Lucia: I'm just putting it here for a bit.
Lucia:  然后找一个锅给它倒进去而已
Lucia: Then I'll find another pot to pour it into.
Lucia:  他这里有没有那种专门的牛奶壶
Lucia: Does he have a special milk pot here?
Lucia:  感觉好像没有什么呃
Lucia: Feels like there's none, uh...
Alice: 应该不会有
Alice: Probably not.
Lucia:  因为如果没有的话
Lucia: Because if there's none,
Lucia:  那个那个锅用来热牛奶就太大了
Lucia: Using that pot to heat milk is too big.
Lucia:  感觉一个热进去才能把他
Lucia: Feels like it would take forever to heat it up.
Alice: 我洗个杯子吧
Alice: I'll wash a cup.
Alice: 我不喝热的
Alice: I don't drink hot beverages.
Lucia:  才能把他盖到底的感觉
Lucia: To really cover it completely.
Lucia:  让我再看看
Lucia: Let me take another look.
Alice: 我们都是用这种杯子是吗
Alice: We're all using these kinds of cups, right?
Lucia:  好像只有这种杯子耶
Lucia: Seems like we only have these cups.
Alice: 哦对好的
Alice: Oh, right, okay.
Alice: 那我洗一个吧
Alice: Then I'll wash one.
Lucia:  但你也可以用碗
Lucia: But you can also use a bowl.
Tasha: 怎么办第一次用这种锅
Tasha: What should I do? It's my first time using this pot.
Lucia:  我觉这个锅用来热牛奶也太
Lucia: I think this pot is too... for heating milk.
Lucia:  哈哈也太但是好像没有别的锅了
Lucia: Haha, but it seems like we don't have any other pot.
Alice: 放油了吗
Alice: Did you add oil?
Tasha: 放了
Tasha: Yes, I did.
Lucia:  要不就暂且用这个吧
Lucia: Maybe we should just use this for now.
Tasha: 我没有用过这个锅煎饼
Tasha: I've never used this pot to make pancakes.
Alice: 啊这这油有点多
Alice: Ah, there's a bit too much oil.
Tasha: 有点多是吧哈哈
Tasha: It's a bit too much, right? Haha.
Alice: 就这样我我
Alice: Just like this, I...
Tasha: 那倒出来一些吧
Tasha: Then pour some out.
Alice: 你你没地方倒吧
Alice: You don't have anywhere to pour it, do you?
Alice: 你就那样吧
Alice: Just leave it as it is.
Alice: 留在锅里一点也没事
Alice: It's fine to leave a bit in the pot.
Alice: 抽油烟机抽油烟机
Alice: Turn on the exhaust fan.
Tasha: 啊好好好熏呀
Tasha: Ah, okay, okay, it's smoky.
Alice: 别闻这个味
Alice: Don't inhale this smell.
Alice: 这个味太
Alice: This smell is too...
Alice: 火还可以
Alice: The flame is fine.
Alice: 小心一点
Alice: Be careful.